This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是人类制作。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇怪的现代世界中，我将剖析心理韧性、体能以及建立抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。播客名称是《回味过去》。那是1979年，对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马可·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not have to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的平台上收听《回味过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的《艰难学艺》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都无法坦诚交流的真诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它。请在iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《艰难学艺》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。艾伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thank you for joining me today for another episode, one that I am really fascinated by beyond excited for and that I think is highly relevant not only in my own life, but amongst many of my fellow 20-something-year-olds, and that is a life beyond the 9 to 5, and how we can kind of leave behind this lifestyle and this conception of work to have more freedom and more flexibility. There has been a lot of personal inspiration for this episode in my life recently.
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客，新听众，老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。感谢你今天和我一起收听又一期节目，这一期节目让我深深着迷、无比兴奋，而且我认为它不仅与我自己的生活高度相关，在我的许多二十多岁同龄人中也是如此，那就是“9到5”工作之外的生活，以及我们如何才能抛弃这种生活方式和对工作的这种观念，从而获得更多的自由和灵活性。最近，我生活中的这期节目带来了很多个人灵感。
If you listened to my episode on Taking Risks, or you follow along with me on Instagram, you will know that I have recently quit my 9 to 5 job to finally pursue the podcast full time. And I'm so excited. I signed with IHeart Radio, who are an incredible partner and an incredible home for this podcast, really believe in the ethos and the vision for the show. And it's been something that I've wanted to do for a while, this show, this podcast. This community is so important to me and it's grown from being just a hobby to the only thing I really ever want to do. I just love making content. I love being able to have the freedom to explore different ideas and to read up and research about all the psychology. It really is
如果你听过我关于“承担风险”的那集节目，或者你在Instagram上关注我，你就会知道我最近辞去了“9到5”的工作，终于开始全职做播客了。我太兴奋了。我签约了iHeartRadio，他们是一个不可思议的合作伙伴，也是这个播客不可思议的归宿，他们真的相信这个节目的精神内核和愿景。这也是我一段时间以来一直想做的事情，这个节目，这个播客。这个社区对我来说非常重要，它已经从一个爱好成长为我唯一真正想做的事情。我就是喜欢创作内容。我喜欢能够拥有自由去探索不同的想法，去阅读和研究所有的心理学。这真的是
the best job in the world. And my decision to do this has also coincided with a lot of disillusionment. I feel that I have with the 9 to 5 work week and the 9 to 5 lifestyle. I think a lot of us in our 20s have become disillusioned with this idea that our lives need to be defined by work, particularly a 9 to 5 office job. There has been this massive shift where we have realized that there is more to life than work and there are actually alternatives in which we can pursue. our lives, pursue our hobbies, enjoy what life has to offer, and also work flexibly and be able to support ourselves. What many of us in this generation are doing is pushing back against this
世界上最好的工作。而我做这个决定的同时，也伴随着许多幻灭感。我觉得我对“9到5”的工作周和“9到5”的生活方式产生了幻灭。我认为我们很多二十多岁的人已经对这种生活需要由工作来定义的想法产生了幻灭，特别是“9到5”的办公室工作。发生了一个巨大的转变，我们意识到生活不仅仅只有工作，实际上还有其他我们可以追求的选择。追求我们的生活，追求我们的爱好，享受生活所提供的东西，同时也能灵活地工作并能够养活自己。我们这一代人中的许多人正在做的事情，就是反抗这种
indoctrinated narrative that life needs to be this very linear journey where we have to follow this very strict blueprint. You know, we graduate high school, we go to university, we get a nine to five job, we work the same job until we're 60, 65 years old. We retire and then we can really start to enjoy life when our youth has already passed, when some of the best days of our lives have actually been consumed by doing all this labor and working really hard for someone else. But I also think we are being confronted with a lot of seriously existential questions around job security and the future of our planet and the world, and we're pushing back against the narrative for more freedom, for more flexibility, and for more joy.
被灌输的叙事，即生活必须是一段非常线性的旅程，我们必须遵循非常严格的蓝图。你知道，我们高中毕业，上大学，找一份朝九晚五的工作，做同一份工作直到60岁、65岁退休，然后当我们的青春已经逝去，当生命中最美好的一些日子实际上已经被用来做所有这些苦力并为别人拼命工作消耗掉时，我们才能真正开始享受生活。但我也认为我们正面临着许多关于工作安全感以及我们星球和世界未来的严重存在主义问题，我们正在为了更多的自由、更多的灵活性和更多的快乐而反抗这种叙事。
Life is so much more than work. But sometimes we forget that because we have been in some ways manipulated or brainwashed by generations of industrial culture and societal pressure into thinking that work is the center of our lives and the center of our universe. I personally deeply disagree with that. And psychology proves this as well and demonstrates to us how our lives greatly improve in quality and our happiness improves as well when we do have a more flexible working condition and we have time to pursue the things that we love, spend quality time with family, out in nature, enjoying our hobbies. And I think that's a life that we can all have.
生活远不止工作。但有时我们忘记了这一点，因为我们在某种程度上被工业文化的世代和社会的压力所操纵或洗脑，认为工作是我们生活的中心，是我们宇宙的中心。我个人对此深表不赞同。心理学也证明了这一点，并向我们展示了当我们拥有更灵活的工作条件，有时间去追求我们热爱的事物，花优质时间陪伴家人，置身大自然中，享受我们的爱好时，我们的生活质量会大大提高，我们的幸福感也会提高。我认为这是我们所有人都能拥有的生活。
there will be different alternatives. My path is not going to be everyone's path, but for everyone, there will be an opportunity to create this lifestyle for yourself. This is a generation that is going to do that. Those of us in our 20s, I think, are more acutely aware of what else is out there, and we are willing to explore that, and I want to encourage that today. So I'm not trying to enlist you in some Ponzi or Pyramid scheme, I promise. This is just my story. And I know this is something that people are interested in because obviously the nine to five job is no longer attractive for many people. It's not necessarily about being your own boss, but fitting work in around life rather than life revolving around work. That's going to look different for different people.
会有不同的选择。我的道路不会是每个人的道路，但对每个人来说，都会有一个为你自己创造这种生活方式的机会。这是一个将要这样做的世代。我们这些二十多岁的人，我认为，对外面的世界有着更敏锐的认识，我们愿意去探索，我今天想鼓励这一点。所以我不是在试图拉你加入什么庞氏骗局或传销，我保证。这只是我的故事。我知道这是人们感兴趣的事情，因为很显然，“9到5”的工作对许多人来说已经不再具有吸引力。这不一定是要成为自己的老板，而是让工作围绕生活展开，而不是生活围绕工作打转。对不同的人来说，这会有所不同。
But I do want to share my experience today about how I have transitioned away from full-time work. I'm hoping this can provide some guidance and also some information. about how I made the choice, what the impact has been on me, some of the psychology behind why I felt my 9 to 5 job was not the best for my mental health or my well-being, and how you can do it too, as well as what are some of the risks to be prepared for? But ultimately, why I think those risks are those that you should be willing to take. So let's jump into it and discuss why it may be time to leave the 9 to 5 lifestyle behind for good. I think implicitly, we know that most office jobs and 9 to 5s are not very natural.
但我今天确实想分享我的经历，关于我是如何从全职工作中转型出来的。我希望这能提供一些指导，以及关于我是如何做出选择的、这对产生了什么影响、为什么我觉得“9到5”的工作不适合我的心理健康或幸福感背后的部分心理学，以及你如何也能做到这一点，还有有哪些风险需要做好准备？但归根结底，为什么我认为这些风险是你应该愿意承担的。所以让我们深入探讨一下，讨论为什么可能是时候永远抛弃“9到5”的生活方式了。我想潜意识里，我们知道大多数办公室工作和“9到5”并不是很自然。
We would much rather be out in nature or creating something beautiful, spending time with family and friends, or simply having the hours in our day to actually get through our to do list and do the things that we need to keep us alive, like grocery shopping. the 9 to 5 removes us from these simple pleasures because it capitalizes on our most productive waking hours. Nine to five jobs are a relic from the past when manufacturing jobs dominated the workforce and was a primary industry in a lot of areas and regions. So Henry Ford, Ford like the car, he was the creator of the Ford, I guess. He was one of the first major business owners to come up this idea of the standard 40-hour work week. And this was based on the demands he was placing
我们宁愿在大自然中，或者创造美好的事物，与家人和朋友共度时光，或者只是在一天中有几个小时来真正完成我们的待办事项清单，做那些我们需要做的事情来维持生存，比如买杂货。“9到5”让我们脱离了这些简单的快乐，因为它资本化了我们最有生产力的清醒时间。朝九晚五的工作是过去的遗物，当时制造业工作在劳动力中占主导地位，是许多领域和地区的主要产业。所以亨利·福特，像汽车那样的福特，他是福特的创造者，我猜。他是最早提出标准40小时工作周这一想法的主要企业主之一。这是基于他对他的人施加的要求
on his factory workers and his manufacturing lines to meet supply and demand requirements for those who wanted to buy his vehicles. That is no longer applicable in most industries. The pandemic in particular, I think, has shown us, as well as many innovative companies and even countries, that allowing people to have more flexible hours or work remotely or even adopt a four-day work week not only increases productivity and innovation, but also overall employee health. The problem with the 9 to 5 as I see it and as psychology sees it, is that it takes up our main productive waking hours and capitalizes on this so that when we're done, we feel exhausted. Also, it never really is a 9 to 5.
在他的工厂工人和制造线上，以满足那些想要购买他的车辆的人的供需需求。这在大多数行业中已经不再适用。特别是大流行病，我认为已经向我们展示了，以及许多创新公司甚至国家，允许人们有更灵活的时间或远程工作，甚至采用四天工作周，不仅可以提高生产力和创新，还可以提高整体员工的健康水平。在我看来以及心理学看来，“9到5”的问题在于，它占用了我们主要的清醒生产时间并将其资本化，以至于当我们完成工作时，我们感到精疲力竭。此外，它从来都不是真正的“9到5”。
like we're sold, it's much more like an 8 to 6 or longer when we account for things like overtime and our commute as well. In my last job, I think it was actually a rarity for me to finish at 5. I worked in consulting, which is infamously known for its very long hours and high pressure environments. And my days were always a lot longer than I had anticipated. Regular office hours, they pose a pretty serious threat to our mood and our mental health for a couple of reasons. So according to a study conducted at Oxford, these hours are not aligned to our circadian rhythm, which dictates when we are going to feel the most productive, most active, and most energized. Most of us can actually not fully focus before 10 a.m., according to this research,
就像我们被推销的那样，当我们考虑到加班和通勤等事情时，它更像是8点到6点甚至更长。在我上一份工作中，我觉得5点下班对我来说其实是一件稀罕事。我从事咨询工作，该行业以工作时间极长和高压环境而闻名。我的日子总是比我预期的要长得多。常规的办公时间对我们的情绪和心理健康构成了相当严重的威胁，原因有几个。根据牛津大学进行的一项研究，这些时间与我们的昼夜节律不一致，昼夜节律决定了我们什么时候会感到最具生产力、最活跃、精力最充沛。根据这项研究，我们大多数人在上午10点之前实际上无法完全集中注意力，
and forcing our brains to jump straight into an activity, straight after sleep, can just leave us feeling more exhausted. Beyond that, I think that a lot of these jobs also encourage inactivity. If we are sedentary, that is bad for our physical health. Sitting down in an office chair, even if your office encourages standing desks or something like that, you're still standing still or sitting still for most of the day. That's not great for our body. Our bodies were made to move. They were made to be active. So encouraging a lifestyle in which that is not always possible is going to put our physical health at risk. They can also be so draining, especially when you're doing something that is not fulfilling.
强迫我们的大脑在睡眠后直接跳入一项活动，只会让我们感到更加精疲力竭。除此之外，我认为很多这样的工作也鼓励了久坐不动。如果我们久坐不动，这对我们的身体健康是不利的。坐在办公室的椅子上，即使你的办公桌鼓励站立式办公桌或类似的东西，你大部分时间仍然是站着不动或坐着不动。这对我们的身体可不太好。我们的身体生来就是要运动的。它们生来就是要保持活跃的。因此，鼓励一种并非总是可能实现这种状态的生活方式，将会把我们的身体健康置于危险之中。它们也可能非常消耗精力，特别是当你做的事情并不能给你带来成就感时。
When we think about it logically, we spend like 60% of our days in an office, almost eight hours or more. And if you feel stressed, if you feel unfulfilled, that is ultimately going to bleed into your overall approach to life. and how we're feeling. Stress in particular has a long-term impact on our body. It's associated with high cortisol levels, which is the stress hormone. And when that remains in our system for too long or when it's repeatedly activated, this impacts on our immune system. It makes us more susceptible to certain illnesses and infections. It also impacts how fast our body ages. And it's linked to a number of mental health conditions. I think stress and the stress associated with 9 to 5 office culture is one component of this equation, but the other is boredom. Perhaps boredom, I think, is the opposite
从逻辑上讲，我们大约60%的日子都在办公室度过，几乎八个小时或更多。如果你感到压力，如果你觉得没有成就感，这最终会渗透到你对生活的整体态度中以及我们的感受。压力对我们的身体有着长期的影响。它与高皮质醇水平有关，皮质醇是压力荷尔蒙。当它在我们的系统中停留时间过长或者被反复激活时，这就会影响我们的免疫系统。它使我们更容易受到某些疾病和感染的影响。它还会影响我们身体衰老的速度。它还与许多心理健康状况有关。我认为压力以及与“9到5”办公室文化相关的压力是这个等式的一个组成部分，但另一个组成部分是无聊。也许无聊，我认为它是
of stress. It's when your work is both unfulfilling and also totally tedious and boring. I'm sure we have all had this experience where we have had to do something that our brain could probably do whilst we were asleep. And our brain deserves stimulation. It deserves a rich environment. In 2014, the psychologists at the University of Virginia, they actually examined this, but they did it by accident. So it was a really simple experiment, and they placed subjects in a room by themselves with no distractions for 10 minutes. And what they wanted to see was our imagination. They wanted to see what our brains would create and give the subjects possibilities to really engage in some of that mental creativity and see what they came up with. But what they actually found was that without stimulation,
压力的对立面。这就是当你的工作既没有成就感，又完全单调乏味的时候。我确信我们都有过这样的经历，我们不得不做一些我们的大脑在我们睡觉时大概也能做的事情。而我们的大脑理应得到刺激。它值得拥有一个丰富的环境。2014年，弗吉尼亚大学的心理学家们实际上研究了这一点，但他们是偶然做的。所以这是一个非常简单的实验，他们把受试者独自放在一个没有任何干扰的房间里10分钟。他们想看的是我们的想象力。他们想看看我们的大脑会创造出什么，并给受试者提供参与其中一些心理创造力的可能性，看看他们想出了什么。但他们实际发现的是，在没有刺激的情况下，
many of the participants became incredibly uncomfortable to the point that when they ran this study again, they gave participants the option to self-administer electric shocks and most of them actually did it just to pass the time. Bortem causes us so much discomfort in our brains, in our bodies, that it can actually increase our drive to take part in behaviors we know are harmful. In the case of this research, that was actually self-inflicting physical pain, but in the real world, we are also more likely to see higher rates of risk behaviors like substance abuse, excessive drinking, gambling, and even reckless driving amongst people who are suffering from excessive boredom like that associated with a tedious, boring job. It also increases our irritability, the number of
许多参与者变得非常不安，以至于当他们再次进行这项研究时，他们给参与者提供了自行实施电击的选项，他们中的大多数人实际上只是为了打发时间而这样做了。无聊在我们的头脑和身体中给我们带来如此大的不适，以至于它实际上会增加我们参与我们明知有害的行为的动力。在这项研究中，这实际上是自加肉体痛苦，但在现实环境中，我们更有可能在遭受过度无聊（例如与单调、枯燥的工作相关的无聊）的人群中看到更高比率的风险行为，如药物滥用、酗酒、赌博甚至鲁莽驾驶。它还会增加我们的易怒性、我们经历的
negative emotions we experience, and our relationships. I think that is such a compelling argument for why we should be seeking out an alternative, especially if you are working in a job that is entirely unfulfilling where you feel completely drained, you feel like you are not contributing to your society and also not even contributing to making your life better. We get one life. Why not spend it? Making amazing memories. Spending quality time, doing the things we love, having flexibility and freedom beyond the office.
负面情绪以及我们的关系。我认为这对于我们为什么要寻找替代方案是一个非常令人信服的论点，特别是如果你从事的是一份完全没有成就感的工作，在那里你感到筋疲力竭，你觉得自己没有为社会做出贡献，甚至没有为让你的生活变得更好做出贡献。我们只有一生。为什么不把它花在创造美好的记忆上。共度美好时光，做我们喜欢的事情，在办公室之外拥有灵活性和自由。
That brings me to my next. reason. I deeply believe that the nine to five job, it causes us to become detached or separated for what truly matters. Work doesn't matter. Work really, it doesn't matter. It's a paycheck in my mind. Maybe that's because I've never really worked in an environment where I've been particularly motivated. You know, my podcast doesn't actually feel like work. It's something that I'm deeply passionate about. And maybe that's how you feel about your job. But I think what can often happen is we become so invested and tied up in the goals of our company or the goals that we have around work that it causes us to forget about what truly matters.
这就把我带到了我的下一个原因。我深信，“9到5”的工作导致我们变得麻木或与真正重要的事情脱节。工作根本不重要。工作真的，它不重要。在我看来，它只是一张工资单。也许那是因为我从来没有在一个我特别有动力环境中工作过。你知道，我的播客实际上不觉得是工作。这是我深深热爱的事情。也许你对你的工作也是这种感觉。但我认为经常发生的情况是，我们变得太投入并被公司的目标或我们围绕工作设定的目标所束缚，以至于导致我们忘记了真正重要的是什么。
We all have stories of people we know who work long hours, not just because they're required to, but because their work has become their personality. And it's not their fault. when you are required to spend the majority of your hours doing something, our brain is going to have a cognitive dissonance and it's going to begin to convince us that we're actually happy in that environment and integrate it into part of our identity. Nine to five jobs, they also just simply take us away from nature and new experiences and time
我们都有过这样的故事：我们认识的人工作时间很长，不仅因为他们必须这样做，而是因为工作已经成为了他们个性的一部分。这并不是他们的错。当你被要求把大部分时间花在做某事上时，我们的大脑就会产生认知失调，并开始说服我们，我们实际上在那样的环境中是快乐的，并将其整合到我们身份的一部分中。“9到5”的工作，它们也只是简单地把我们从大自然、新体验和时间中拉开
to do things that we love. It's not just the hours, right? It's not just that nine to five are our primary waking hours. it's the fact that most of us only get four weeks of holiday time, four weeks to actually go out and explore our environment, to make new memories with the people we love. That was really compelling for me when I was making my decision. But before I get to my experience, I do just want to bring up this other theory, which I really believe in, and that is that the nine to five job and office jobs in particular actually separate us from our instinctual. urges. And from an evolutionary standpoint, they are highly unnatural. So our ancestors, our very
去做我们喜欢的事情。这不仅仅是时间的问题，对吧？不仅是“9到5”占据了我们主要的清醒时间，而是我们大多数人只有四周的假期，只有四周的时间去真正出去探索我们的环境，与我们爱的人创造新的记忆。当我做决定时，这对我真的很有吸引力。但在我讲到我的经历之前，我只想提出另一个理论，我对此深信不疑，那就是“9到5”的工作，尤其是办公室工作，实际上将我们与我们的本能冲动隔离开来。而且从演化的角度来看，它们是非常不自然的。所以我们的祖先，非常
early ancestors, they spent their days problem solving and roaming around, exploring new environments, foraging and hunting and being stimulated by multiple things in their environment. They had to use different parts of their brains, different parts of their bodies to survive and to essentially, will live and support their kin and their children and their offspring. And what that led to was a very well-adapted, complex brain, the same brain that we still have today. And our brain wants the same things. It wants to be entertained. It wants to problem solve. It wants to be able to explore and use its senses and use its functions to fulfill our goals and our desires and our objectives. When we we put our brain into an environment that is not conducive to that, like a very stale office or
早期的祖先，他们白天花时间解决问题、四处游荡、探索新环境、寻找食物、狩猎，并受到环境中多种事物的刺激。他们必须使用大脑的不同部分、身体的不同部分来生存，并从根本上活着并支持他们的亲属、孩子和后代。这带来了一个适应良好、复杂的大脑，也就是我们今天仍然拥有的相同的大脑。而我们的大脑想要同样的东西。它想要被娱乐。它想要解决问题。它想要能够探索并使用它的感官和功能来满足我们的目标、愿望和目的。当我们把我们的大脑置于一个不利于这一点的环境中，比如一个非常陈旧的办公室，或者
into hours that don't actually fit around our circadian rhythm and our natural urges, we cut ourselves off from those instincts, from our inherent nature. Obviously, it's nice to have security. Our priorities have obviously changed. We no longer need to go and forage or gather or hunt our food. It's a great, great step forward. I don't think I would have survived in that environment. But I do also believe that it's been taken too far to a point where sometimes our jobs don't even give us the financial freedom to afford the things that we need, and yet they take up so much of our time.
置于不符合我们昼夜节律和自然冲动的时间里，我们就将自己从这些本能、从我们固有的天性中切断了。很明显，拥有安全感是件好事。我们的优先事项显然已经改变了。我们不再需要去寻找或采集或狩猎我们的食物。这是一个巨大、巨大的进步。我想我无法在那种环境中生存下来。但我也相信它已经被推得太远了，以至于有时我们的工作甚至没有给我们提供负担我们所需东西的财务自由，然而它们却占据了我们这么多的时间。
This is where my disillusionment stemmed from. And I want to talk about my experience just for a little bit here. I think I have always known that the nine to five job wasn't going to be for me. I always had these dreams about starting my own business or being an entertainer or doing something that gave me more flexibility and room to explore. But I graduated from university and the next natural step for me was to go and get a job. And at the time, the job that I got, I thought that was my job. dream job. I genuinely was elated. I was so excited when I knew that I was going to be starting with this
这就是我的幻灭感的根源。我想在这里稍微谈谈我的经历。我想我一直都知道“9到5”的工作不适合我。我一直梦想着开创自己的事业，或者成为一名艺人，或者做一些能给我更多灵活性和探索空间的事情。但我大学毕业了，对我来说最自然的下一步就是去找一份工作。当时我找到的那份工作，我以为那是我的梦想工作。我由衷地欣喜若狂。当我得知我将要加入这家公司时，我太兴奋了。
company. And they were a great company. They were amazing. I do genuinely love my co-workers and some of the things I was able to work on. But a massive part of me also felt really, really unfulfilled. I said it before, but I was working in consulting. And the hours, they are not 9 to 5. They are, for me sometimes it was like 7 a.m. to 9 p.m. That did not give me time to enjoy my life. Like, none at all. And I was quite frankly miserable. I was really suffering. I wasn't sleeping. I never had time to exercise. I was trying to squeeze in time to socialize with my friends. Normally that went, you know, going out for drinks after work, which is always fun, but I kind of wanted a little bit more. I wanted to be able to go to the beach with them or go to an art gallery or do something.
他们是一家伟大的公司。他们太棒了。我真心喜欢我的同事，也喜欢我能够参与的一些工作。但我的内心深处也有很大一部分感到非常非常没有成就感。我以前说过，我从事的是咨询工作。而且工作时间，它们不是9点到5点。对我有的时候就像早上7点到晚上9点。这根本没有给我时间去享受生活。一点也没有。坦白说，我当时苦不堪言。我真的在受折磨。我没有睡觉。我从来没有时间锻炼。我一直在努力挤出时间与朋友社交。通常那是，你知道的，下班后出去喝一杯，这总是很有趣，但我其实想要更多一点。我希望能够和他们一起去海滩，或者去美术馆，或者做一点
something a little bit more fulfilling and productive. And I was finding that I did not have that opportunity alongside that I was doing my podcast alongside working. And I know that that was a self-inflicted burden, but it just ate into all of my time that I would usually be devoting to my hobbies. And it was a huge adjustment. One that I think I never really did adjust to. I said it before, but I was I was genuinely miserable. I was so sad. I was depressed. I really felt incredibly unfulfilled. I felt so unfulfilled. And I was blessed enough to have this thing, this podcast that I knew I wanted to do full time. Because this was what made me feel alive. This was what made me feel motivated. I can spend 12 hours a day working on this show because I feel so happy doing that and content.
更有成就感、更有成效的事情。我发现我没有那个机会，除此之外，我还在工作之余做我的播客。我知道那是自己给自己强加的负担，但这侵占了我通常会用来发展爱好的所有时间。这是一个巨大的调整。一个我想我从来没有真正适应过的调整。我以前说过，我当时真的是苦不堪言。我太难过了。我很沮丧。我真的感到无比的空虚。我感到太空虚了。而我有幸拥有了这个东西，这个我知道我想全职去做的播客。因为这让我觉得自己还活着。这让我感到有动力。我可以花一天12个小时在这个节目上工作，因为我那样做感到非常快乐和满足。
and I feel like I'm making a difference, but spending 12, 14 hours, working for someone else in an office, doing tedious tasks, was just, it wasn't it. And the interesting thing was, whilst I was going through this experience, I was having so many conversations with my friends
我觉得我在做出改变，但是花12、14个小时，在办公室里为别人打工，做着单调乏味的任务，真的，那不是我想要的。有趣的是，当我经历这段经历时，我和我的朋友们进行了那么多的对话，
who felt the exact same way. And some of them actually took the leap and decided to go out on their own or do something different. I think it was this one conversation I had with my friend where I realized how quickly the last three years of my life had gone by. And I was looking through my camera roll. And yes, there was a highlight reel. But most of the time, it was empty. It was empty of experiences. It was empty of fulfillment. And so many people in my life
他们有着完全相同的感受。他们中的一些人甚至真的迈出了这一步，决定自己单干或者做点不一样的。我想正是与朋友的这次对话，让我意识到过去三年的生活是多么快地流逝了。我翻看着手机相册。是的，有一些精彩的瞬间。但大多数时候，它是空的。里面没有经历，没有成就感。我生命中的许多人
were saying the same thing. So many people in their 20s were becoming so disillusioned with this idea that we had been sold. It almost felt like a bit of a Trojan horse. Like we had offered this amazing idea of security and of a purpose and of financial freedom. And none of those things were really coming true for us. I have friends who are working ridiculous hours for such little pay. Like we sat down and it was when you account for the hours they work overtime compared to their base salary, they were making less than minimum wage. That is a hard pill to swallow. That is a hard dream to keep pursuing if you never feel like. you are getting any reward. So I decided to quit. I decided to leave it behind and it was really
也在说同样的话。许多二十多岁的人对我们被兜售的这种想法感到如此幻灭。它感觉有点像木马计。就像我们被许诺了安全感、目标感和财务自由这样一个美好的概念，而这些东西对我们来说都没有真正实现。我有朋友为了微薄的薪水而工作疯狂的长时间。我们坐下来算过，当你把他们加班的工作时间与基本薪资相提并论时，他们赚的钱比最低工资还要少。这是一个很难接受的现实。如果你觉得永远得不到任何回报，这是一个很难继续追求的梦想。所以我决定辞职。我决定把它抛在脑后，这真的
terrifying. I think that like many of us, my family and the culture and the society around me had never really shown me success stories of what it would look like if I didn't pursue this way of life, what it would look like to exist outside the realm of the nine to five. So it was terrifying. It was genuinely really terrifying. And I wished that I had someone who had done it before me, who could have sat me down and said, it's all going to be okay. And now I'm that person. I'm that person for anyone out there who is thinking, should I do this? The answer is yes. The answer is yes. My whole life and my attitude towards life has completely changed with this transition. And it ranges from really small things. Like, I found that,
太吓人了。我想和我们许多人一样，我的家庭、文化以及我周围的社会从来没有真正向我展示过这样的成功故事：如果我不追求这种生活方式会是什么样子，存在于“9到5”领域之外会是什么样子。所以这太吓人了。这真的是太吓人了。我希望我能有一个以前做过这件事的人，他能把我拉坐下来，告诉我，一切都会好起来的。现在我成了那个人。对于任何正在思考“我该这么做吗？”的人，我就是那个人。答案是肯定的。答案是肯定的。我整个人生以及我对生活态度随着这次转变发生了彻底的改变。这从非常小的事情开始。比如，我发现，
I'm eating better because I'm not constantly overworked and just looking for something that is convenient. I have time to actually invest in putting good food into my body. I have time to exercise. The other day, I went for a walk in the sun and I realized that like the last two, three years, except for on the weekends, there were so many days where I never went outdoors. And that just felt so unnatural for me because that is how we are meant to exist. We are meant to be outside. We were meant to be exploring nature. And just having that opportunity to do that was such a small joy and it was so beautiful. I will say I'm not working less hours.
我吃得更好了，因为我不再过度劳累，只是在寻找方便的东西。我有时间真正投资把好食物吃进我的肚子里。我有时间锻炼。有一天，我去阳光下散步，我意识到在过去的两三年里，除了周末，有很多天我从不出门。这对我来说感觉太不自然了，因为这就是我们应该生存的方式。我们应该在户外。我们本该去探索大自然。能够有那个机会去这样做是一种如此微小的快乐，它是如此美丽。我要说的是，我并没有减少工作时间。
I think I'm working more. But that's just because I'm more motivated than ever to just explore and put out amazing content and write great episodes. I just can't stop myself. I'm a little bit of a perfectionist and a workaholic in that way. But I realize the hours were kind of never the problem. It was my sense of fulfillment and it was my sense of flexibility. And that's the most beautiful thing that I think this lifestyle offers is that you can decide when you wake up. You can decide how much effort you really put in, which is, I guess, correlated with your output in a way that you can't do when you're working in an office and people require things from you.
我想我工作得更多了。但这只是因为我比以往任何时候都更有动力去探索、推出精彩的内容并撰写精彩的节目。我就是无法停下来。在这方面我有点完美主义和工作狂。但我意识到工作时间从来都不是问题。问题在于我的成就感和灵活性。我认为这种生活方式提供的最美好的事情是，你可以决定什么时候起床。你可以决定你真正投入了多少努力，这在某种程度上与你的产出相关，这是你在办公室工作、别人对你有所要求时无法做到的。
But you can also set your own schedule. The other day, I know I'm giving so many examples here, but when I moved to Sydney, the thing is that you're going to Sydney, the thing is that you can't. that was so attractive to me was being able to go to the beach and I would only be able to go on the weekends and now I can go in the middle of the day. That freedom is so beautiful. That freedom is like insanely special to me to be able to actually prioritize the things in my life that I want to do. I know it's another common experience whereby one of my friends said this to me the other day, we make this money at our nine to five jobs. It's a secure wage. It's a secure income, which I think we cannot understate. But then we actually don't have time to spend it because
但你也可以设定自己的日程安排。有一天，我知道我在这里给出了太多的例子，但当我搬到悉尼时，事情就是，你去了悉尼，事情就是，你不能。对我来说最有吸引力的是能够去海滩，以前我只能在周末去，现在我可以在大白天去。那种自由太美妙了。对我来说，这种自由极其特别，能够真正把生活中我想做的事情放在首位。我知道这是另一种普遍的经历，我的一个朋友前几天对我说，我们在“9到5”的工作中赚了这些钱。这是一份有保障的工资。这是一份有保障的收入，我认为这是我们不能低估的。但接着我们实际上没有时间去花它，因为
nothing's really open after 5pm. The sun is set. You can online shop, you can do those things, but those are not as gratifying as being able to go out and do things with your friends and actually spend the money in a way that you want to rather than just on one holiday or one. one trip a year. So I think the main thing and the main message I want to communicate is that the risk has been worth it for me. I have been able to transform my life in a way that I always dreamed of in a way that is so much better for my lifestyle and so productive. I will say maybe none of this is aligning with your experience. Some people love their jobs. They love their co-workers. they do find ways to balance their work and their life in order to prioritize the things they do
下午5点以后基本上什么都不开门。太阳已经落山了。你可以在网上购物，你可以做那些事情，但那些不如和朋友出去做事情、真正以你想要的方式花钱更有满足感，而不是只花在一年的一次假期或一次旅行上。所以我认为我想传达的主要事情和主要信息是，对我来说，这个风险是值得的。我能够以我一直梦想的方式改造我的生活，以一种对我的生活方式好得多、更有成效的方式。我要说的是，也许这一切并不符合你的经历。有些人热爱他们的工作。他们热爱他们的同事。他们确实找到了平衡工作和生活的方法，以便将他们真正喜欢做的事情放在首位。如果你是这样的人，我认为这太棒了。但我也认为，在我们的一生中，至少会有那么一次或某个时刻，那种生活方式受到质疑，我们会寻找一条不同的前行之路。
enjoy doing. And if that is you, I think that that is incredible. But I think as well, there will be at least one time or one point in our lives where that way of living is called into question and we're going to look for a different way forward. There's another thing I want to say and that is I don't want to disregard that this is a privilege. Not everyone has this opportunity. They need the security of full-time work to support children, to pay mortgages, to pay their bills, to put food on the table. And I understand that.
还有一件事我想说，那就是我不想忽视这是一个特权。不是每个人都有这个机会。他们需要全职工作的保障来抚养孩子、支付抵押贷款、支付账单、把食物端上餐桌。我理解这一点。
I also have to support myself. And I have gotten really lucky. I think that kind of goes without saying. But what I really am trying to say is that is the 9 to 5 work week really the best that society can come up with. And if you had the opportunity to work more flexible hours, to have that freedom, would you take it? And I think our answer is yes, because inherently, we know that what we are putting our brains and our minds and our bodies through is not natural or efficient. Society isn't what it used to be, and we have adapted. So our work should as well.
我也必须养活自己。我真的很幸运。我想这不言而喻。但我真正想说的是，“9到5”的工作周真的是社会能想出的最好的办法吗？如果你有机会工作更灵活的时间，拥有那种自由，你会接受吗？我想我们的答案是肯定的，因为从根本上讲，我们知道我们让大脑、思想和身体经历的事情是不自然、低效的。社会已经今非昔比，我们已经适应了。所以我们的工作也应该如此。
even stable jobs no longer provide the security that we are often sold or that we crave. Think about how many news articles there are a week about people being laid off from companies that they've worked for for years. And even massive players like Google, they still can't provide the security of full-time forever employment that's been sold to us as part of this deal, this deal whereby we exchange the best hours and the best years of our life, for security, and that's not even promised. The world, I think, has also become more globalized and innovative and entrepreneurial. The rise of the internet and social media and technology means that
即使是稳定的工作也不再提供我们经常被推销或渴望的安全感。想想每周有多少关于人们从工作了多年的公司被解雇的新闻文章。甚至像谷歌这样的大公司，仍然无法提供作为这笔交易的一部分向我们兜售的永久全职就业的安全感，这是一笔我们用生命中最美好的时间和最美好的岁月去换取安全感的交易，而这甚至都没有保证。我认为世界也变得更加全球化、创新和具有创业精神。互联网、社交媒体和技术的兴起意味着
our income is no longer tied to a concrete office space that we have to habitually return to. So, what I want to step into next is when we can identify that it's time to leave this routine and break away, what the risks entails and also what some of my personal fears were and still are, but how to be prepared to enter into that world and that lifestyle of more freedom. When do we know that it's time to go? That's a big question. And I don't know if I can answer it, but there are a few tell-tale signs that I think it's time for you to take the risk.
我们的收入不再与我们必须习惯性返回的具体办公室空间挂钩。所以，我接下来要探讨的是，当我们能够认出是时候离开这个常规并打破常规时，风险意味着什么，以及我个人的一些恐惧过去是什么、现在是什么，但如何准备好进入那种拥有更多自由的世界和生活方式。我们什么时候才知道是时候离开了？这是一个大问题。我不知道自己是否能回答它，但有几个明显的迹象表明，我认为是时候让你承担风险了。
The first is when your job is negatively impacting your job. your mental health. There are some things that we're willing to tolerate, right? Like, there are discrete times in our lives where we know we are going to go through more acute levels of stress and anxiety, or even just randomly, we all go through our own mental health peaks and troughs. That's a part of life. But when you can identify that it is your work that is correlated to those mental health struggles, there is nothing worth jeopardizing that for. Absolutely nothing. I've been there. I've done that. And I've come out the other side and when I look back, all I can say is that hindsight gives you a completely different perspective. And I wish that when I was
首先是当你的工作对你的工作产生负面影响时。你的心理健康。有些事情是我们愿意容忍的，对吧？比如，在我们生命中有明确的时间，我们知道我们将经历更剧烈的压力和焦虑，或者甚至只是随机地，我们都会经历我们自己的心理健康高峰和低谷。那是生活的一部分。但当你能确定是你的工作与那些心理健康挣扎相关时，没有什么比这更值得冒险了。绝对没有。我去过那里。我做过那件事。我从另一边走了出来，当我回过头看时，我只能说后见之明给了你一个完全不同的视角。我希望当我
going through those periods, when I could identify that it was my job that was causing all of that distress, I'd made the call sooner to walk away. Your mental health is the most important thing. There is always another alternative. There is always another job. There is always another job. There is always another opportunity that you can take. I think the second reason is when you feel a calling for something else. I know that sounds really wishy-washy. It's not incredibly tangible. We can't always tell when a feeling is right, but you need to trust your intuition. An intuition is basically our brain paying subconscious attention to things that we don't always consciously recognize. It's the age old saying to trust your gut, and I truly do believe that when we have a compelling
经历那些时期时，当我能确定是我的工作导致了所有这些痛苦时，我能更早地做出离开的决定。你的心理健康是最重要的事。总有另一种选择。总有另一份工作。总有另一份工作。总有另一个你可以抓住的机会。我认为第二个原因是你感到对其他事情有所召唤。我知道这听起来很不切实际。它并不总是那么切实。我们并不总能分辨出一种感觉是否正确，但你需要相信你的直觉。直觉基本上是我们的大脑对我们并不总是有意识识别的事物给予潜意识的关注。这是一个古老的说法，相信你的直觉，我真的相信，当我们有一个引人注目的
instinct to take a risk or to do something against the grain, something different, it is our responsibility to explore that or we risk regretting it. If you listened to my episode on why we should take risks in our 20s, you'll have heard the study already, but it is so powerful for me. These researchers, they found that people are more likely to regret the actions that they didn't take or the decisions that they walked away from or didn't make compared to those that they did. That was one of the final straws for me, actually reading that study and realizing that although there was a lot at stake, things could go wrong. The chances that I would regret my decision were going to be a lot higher if I passed up this opportunity. rather than if I ran towards it.
本能去承担风险或做一些违背常理、与众不同的事情时，我们有责任去探索它，否则我们会有后悔的风险。如果你听过我关于为什么我们应该在二十多岁时冒险的那集节目，你就会听到这项研究，但它对我有很大的启发。这些研究人员发现，与那些采取了行动的人相比，人们更有可能对他们没有采取的行动或他们走开或没有做出的决定感到后悔。实际上，那是压垮我的最后一根稻草之一，当我读到那项研究并意识到虽然有很多利害关系，事情可能会出错时。如果我错过这个机会，我后悔决定的几率要比我奔向它高得多。
It's also worth acknowledging that you are an incredibly adaptive person. Generations of your ancestors have survived and survived much worse things to get you to this point. There is always a solution. There is always a way forward. Even if things go wrong, you will find a way through and you don't want to risk that idea of what if things had gone well, what if this had worked out. Another reason it may be time to leave your job, to think about a life beyond the nine to five, is if you feel undervalued and overlooked.
同样值得承认的是，你是一个适应能力极强的人。你的祖先几代人都生存了下来，并且在比这更糟糕的事情中生存下来，才把你带到了这一点。总有一个解决办法。总有一条前进的道路。即使事情出了差错，你也会找到出路，你不想冒那种“如果事情进展顺利会怎样”、“如果这行得通会怎样”的想法的风险。你可能想要离开工作的另一个原因，去思考“9到5”以外的生活，就是如果你觉得自己被低估和忽视了。
That is terrible for our self-esteem. And it bleeds into our well-being and our health and how we treat other people. If you are working in a job where you are doing so much work, you are putting in the hours and you are not getting the credit you deserve, there is no point staying there. There is another company that will treat you with respect, but you can also be your own boss and show yourself the respect that you deserve because it's coming from you. This next reason, I know it's not a new one everywhere all over my TikTok, all over my Instagram. I see this idea of the side hustle. So essentially, it is an activity or kind of a job that you work beyond your 9 to 5 that provides you with a second income.
这对我们的自尊心打击太大了。而且它会波及我们的幸福感、健康以及我们对待别人的方式。如果你从事一份工作，付出大量心血，加班加点，却得不到应有的认可，那么留在那儿就毫无意义。会有另一家公司尊重你，但你也可以成为自己的老板，向自己展示你应得的尊重，因为这源于你自己。这第二个原因，我知道这并不是什么新鲜事，我的TikTok和Instagram到处都是。我经常看到副业这个概念。所以本质上，它是一项活动或一种工作，你在朝九晚五的工作之余去做，能为你带来第二份收入。
I've been skeptical about this. I was like, some of these do not seem real. I'm not even going to look into this. But then I was like, I guess my podcast was somewhat of a side hustle, even though I really wasn't making any money until recently. Side hustles can actually be anything. They can be anything. And they don't even need to make you money.
我以前对此持怀疑态度。我想，其中有些看起来太假了。我甚至懒得去了解。但后来我想，我猜我的播客也算是一种副业，尽管直到最近我基本上都没赚到什么钱。副业其实可以是什么都行。它们可以是什么都行。甚至不需要能为你赚钱。
But if there is a way to make money and to support yourself with that, even if it's going to make or take more effort and time, you should do it because you could produce a higher payoff. And my final reason is no reason at all. If you are just called to live differently, you should do it. This is your life. You do not, no one owns it. You do not owe anything to anyone. You are solely responsible for what you want to do and what you want to achieve and the kind of life that you want to live. That is your responsibility. So if you feel called to live differently, you don't need a reason. You may love your workplace.
但如果有办法赚钱并以此养活自己，哪怕这需要付出更多的努力和时间，你也应该去做，因为你可能会获得更高的回报。而我的最后一个原因其实根本不算原因。如果你只是内心渴望一种不同的生活方式，你就应该去做。这是你的人生。你不需要，没有人拥有它。你不欠任何人任何东西。你完全要对自己想做的事、想实现的成就以及想过的生活负责。那是你的责任。所以，如果你觉得内心渴望过上不同的生活，你不需要理由。你可能很热爱你的工作场所。
You may be getting paid a lot, but it just doesn't align with your priorities or your vision for your life. It may be time to consider whether there is another alternative. So the next stage is you've made the decision. You're leaving the cozy 9 to 5 or office job life behind. What's next? What's the next steps here? We're not going to be naive or blaze here. Leaving behind the security of a frequent and consistent paycheck and full-time hours is going to be scary.
你可能薪水很高，但它就是不符合你的优先事项或你对人生的愿景。也许是时候考虑是否有其他选择了。所以下一个阶段就是你做出了决定。你将舒适的朝九晚五或办公室生活抛在脑后。接下来是什么？接下来的步骤是什么？我们在这里可不能天真或鲁莽。抛弃一份薪水丰厚稳定、全职时间的安稳工作是会让人感到害怕的。
And there are some factors to consider. I cannot tell you how many hours and nights I've spent considering every way that this could go wrong. How I could be broke by 30. I could lose my voice and no longer work. That's like a crazy thing to me. I could get sued. I could lose my inspiration. I could lose my passion for this. That's probably the scariest one. Or, you know, one day people just aren't interested anymore. But the thing that I think of when I'm thinking these things and when I'm finding myself in a spiral or really ruminating
而且有一些因素需要考虑。我无法告诉你我花了多少个小时和夜晚去考虑这件事可能出错的所有方式。我可能在30岁时破产。我可能会失声而无法再工作。对我来说这太疯狂了。我可能会被告。我可能会失去灵感。我可能会失去对此的热情。这可能最让人害怕。或者，你知道，有一天人们不再感兴趣了。但每当我想到这些事情，当我发现自己陷入死胡同或陷入沉思时，我脑子里想的是
is that even when I, this wasn't my job, even when I was making no money, I was still doing this because I loved it. And if I'm doing something I love, maybe it's naive, but I do think that nothing can go wrong. There will always be a way when there's a will. There's a way. But I also chose to be realistic. There is, you know, daydreaming and there is fantasy thinking and sometimes that naivety can get us in trouble. So I put some things in place before I took the leap. This is just my perspective. This is what I chose to do. You can take my advice or leave it, as is always the case. But if you are serious about leaving the nine to five, and corporate lifestyle behind, these are some tangible and valuable steps that I think you can take
即便在我这不是工作的时候，即使我一分钱也赚不到，我依然在做这件事，因为我热爱它。如果我在做自己热爱的事，也许这很天真，但我确实认为没有什么会出错了。世上无难事，只怕有心人。只要有决心，总会有办法的。但我也选择保持现实。你知道，有白日梦和幻想思维，有时这种天真会给我们带来麻烦。所以在迈出这一步之前，我做了一些准备。这只是我的个人观点。这是我选择的做法。你可以采纳我的建议，也可以不听，一如既往。但如果你是认真的想告别朝九晚五和企业生活，我认为你可以采取这些切实且有价值的步骤
to ensure yourself more long-term security. The first one is to do with money. You need to have at least three to six months of money saved up to cover your expenses or some fallback or some form of financial security that you can fall back on. It's a sad reality that we need money to live, but it is reality. You need to be able to take care of your health, your dependents, maybe you have a mortgage or just your bills. So you don't want to be in a situation in which you're really desperate or in which you are forced to go back on your desires or go back on your goal or your intentions. So an easy way to do that is to make sure that you have enough money to save up if things go wrong. And it will also just provide you with a
来确保自己获得更多长期的安全感。第一点和金钱有关。你需要至少存下三到六个月的生活费来应付开支，或者有一些后备方案或某种财务安全网，以便在你需要时有所依靠。我们需要钱才能生活，这是一个残酷的现实，但这就是现实。你需要能够照顾好你的健康、你的家属，也许你背着房贷或者仅仅是要付账单。所以你绝对不想陷入那种真正绝望的境地，或者被迫违背自己的愿望、违背自己的目标或初衷。一个简单的方法就是确保你有足够的存款，以防万一出了什么差错。这也会为你提供一个
greater sense of security so that you feel you can take the risk. This may take time. It took me, just under like eight months to get to this point. So I really wouldn't advise listening to this episode and going and giving your four weeks tomorrow. I think it is important to be realistic, but this really helped me to know that even if everything went wrong, I still would have a bit of a buffer to get back on my feet and to pay my rent and do all the things that I needed to do. I also think this grows hand in hand with having a good look at what you are spending. your money on. This is advice for any transition, but especially one that comes with financial risk. I sat down, I went through all my bank statements, and oh my goodness, I spent money on so many
更强烈的安全感，让你觉得你可以承担风险。这可能需要时间。我花了不到八个月的时间才走到这一点。所以我真的不建议听完这一集节目，明天就去交辞职信。我认为保持现实很重要，但这确实帮我了解到，即使一切都出了问题，我仍然有一点缓冲来东山再起，付房租并做我需要做的一切。我也认为这与仔细审视你的钱花在什么地方是相辅相成的。这是针对任何转型的建议，特别是伴随着财务风险的转型。我坐下来，查看了所有的银行对账单，天哪，我在好多
ridiculous things. I found like a $40 order for slime. And I distinctly remember buying this slime, like a few months back. But I was like, that is, I do not need that slime. There are things that I can cut out of my daily expenses, of my luxury purchases. I don't think slime, is a luxury, but whatever that means for you, that is going to make me feel more secure and more able to provide myself with financial security. So have a good look at what you can maybe cut out, what maybe you'll have to give up, and if you're willing to give those things up, or if you, I guess what state you need to be and to not have to do those things. And have a game plan. There is nothing worse than stepping into a new and novel situation and having no idea of your way forward.
荒谬的东西上花了钱。我发现了一笔40美元买史莱姆的订单。我清楚地记得几个月前买过这个史莱姆。但我想，这东西，我根本不需要那个史莱姆。有些开支我可以从日常开销和奢侈消费中砍掉。我不认为史莱姆是奢侈品，但无论这对你意味着什么，那些能让我感到更有安全感、更有能力为自己提供财务安全感的东西。所以好好看看你可能可以削减什么，你可能需要放弃什么，以及你是否愿意放弃这些东西，或者我猜你需要处于什么状态才不必做那些事情。还要制定一个作战计划。没有什么比踏入一个全新且陌生的情况却对前路茫茫毫无头绪更糟糕的了。
there is a healthy level of risk and then there is an unhealthy level of risk and I think the distinction there is having somewhat of an idea of where you're going to next. So I made sure that I had written up a game plan. I had an idea of what I was going to do on my, even in my day to day, what my priorities and my focus was and what my long term goals were and making sure that I was oriented towards that and making sure that my decision was actually aligned with this vision I had for my life and my game plan. The other thing to do, especially if you're leaving a big company or a corporate job, is to end on good terms. Worst case scenario, you can go back to that job and you can go back to that security. If you leave on bad terms, if you leave on bad terms,
理性的风险与非理性的风险是有区别的，我认为两者的区别在于是否对下一步去哪里有一个大致的概念。所以我确保自己写好了作战计划。我大致知道自己要做什么，甚至在日常生活中，我的重点和优先级是什么，我的长期目标是什么，并确保自己朝着这个方向努力，确保我的决定确实符合我对人生的愿景和我的作战计划。另一件要做的事，特别是如果你要离开大公司或企业工作，就是好聚好散。最坏的情况是，你还可以回到那份工作，回到那种安全感中。如果你闹得不欢而散，如果你闹得不欢而散，
I think you just eliminate a bit of a security blanket. You eliminate something that could catch you if you fall. So most companies would love to have you back. They don't want to invest however much money it costs to train someone new. So make sure that you have that backup plan and leave on good terms in the back of your mind. It will also make you feel a lot more secure and stable in your decision. understand how you're going to create routine and a support network or community around this new path. I'm not going to sugarcoat this. It can be really lonely, especially in this industry and with my job.
我认为你只是抹杀了一层安全网。你消除了一个在你跌倒时能接住你的东西。所以大多数公司都很乐意欢迎你回来。他们不想在培训新人上投入那么多资金。所以一定要在心底保留这个备用计划，并且好聚好散。这也会让你对自己的决定感到更加安全和稳定。明白你将如何围绕这个新路径建立日常习惯以及支持网络或社群。我不会粉饰太平。这真的会很孤独，尤其是在这个行业和我的工作中。
It's like, this is a solo, a solo enterprise. This is a solo pursuit. There is not much of a community around podcasting, at least in Australia. I have had the benefit and the pleasure of being able to meet some other people who are doing this as their work. But that was intentional. I knew that I was someone who needed community around me. I am an extrovert. I need people who I can complain about my work problems too, who are going to be there for me. So that was one of the biggest challenges moving away from the solid structure of a 9 to 5 job, was knowing that I would have to say goodbye to that inbuilt community and wanting to find an
这就好像，这是一个人的企业。这是一场人的追寻。播客周围并没有太多的社群，至少在澳大利亚是这样。我有幸能够结识一些也把这当成工作的人。但这并非偶然。我知道自己是一个身边需要社群的人。我是一个外向的人。我需要能够向其倾诉工作问题、且能在我身边支持我的人。所以离开朝九晚五工作的稳固结构带来的最大挑战之一，就是知道自己将不得不告别那种内置的社群，并渴望找到一个
alternative. I think also this is another financial one. Maybe I should have said this earlier. Firstly, have a realistic expectation of if this is a side hustle or a business that you're starting, what that's going to cost. There are some upfront costs. There are some long-term costs that I didn't expect. But also don't stop putting money towards your superannuation or your retirement. This was advice that my mom gave me. Shout out to my mom. She's an economist. She provides great financial advice. But in Australia, we have this thing called superannuation and your employer immediately has to put money into that fund for you. I didn't think about this, but when I stopped working a nine to five job, I'm my employer now. I have to put money towards that. So that's a big
替代方案。我认为这也是另一个关于金钱的问题。也许我应该早点说这个。首先，要对这如果是你正在开展的副业或业务，会产生什么成本有一个现实的期望。有一些前期成本。还有一些我没预料到的长期成本。但同时不要停止向你的养老金或退休账户存钱。这是我妈妈给我的建议。向我妈妈致敬。她是一名经济学家。她提供了很好的理财建议。但在澳大利亚，我们有一种叫养老金的东西，雇主必须立即把钱存入那个基金。我以前没考虑过这个，但当我停止朝九晚五的工作时，我就是自己的雇主了。我必须自己把钱存进去。所以这是一个重大
thing to consider. Obviously, there are financial considerations. There are a lot of other considerations. If you have children, consider the impact on them. If you have a mortgage, consider whether you can pay your mortgage or whether this might be too much of a risk. But risks are always going to be there. They are inherent in every part of our life, every single facet and element. So it's about what level of risk you are willing to tolerate for a greater reward. And this is just one woman's opinion, but I do think that this is one of the greatest choices you can make. Us 20 year olds, us in this generation, I think we know that 9 to 5 work is not the fantasy, it's not the dream that was sold to us. So we're looking for something else. And it's possible. We want to enjoy our
需要考虑的事情。显然，有财务方面的考量。还有很多其他考量。如果你有孩子，考虑一下对他们的影响。如果你有房贷，考虑一下你是否能还得起房贷，或者这是否风险太大。但风险将永远存在。它们是生活每个部分、每个面向和要素所固有的。所以关键在于，为了更大的回报，你愿意容忍什么程度的风险。这只是一个女性的观点，但我确实认为这是你能做出的最伟大的选择之一。我们二十几岁的人，我们这一代人，我认为我们知道朝九晚五的工作并不是神话，不是推销给我们的梦想。所以我们在寻找别的东西。这是可能的。我们想要享受
lives. You only have one of them and being able to work flexibly, work remotely, be your own boss is such a rewarding alternative. And I said it before, but I just really want to say it again, regardless of if you're listening to this and being like, actually, you know, I don't think I'm willing to take this risk. I'm going to stay in my job. It doesn't matter. Life is not work. your life should not have to exist in the corners around your work hours. Life is the thing that happens to you every day. It's the thing that is made up of beautiful joys and beautiful memories and incredible connections.
生活。你只有一次生命，能够灵活工作、远程工作、做自己的老板，是如此有回报的替代方案。我之前说过，但我真的很想再强调一遍，不管你听了这些之后觉得“其实，你知道，我觉得我不敢冒这个险。我要留在工作岗位上。”这都没关系。生活不只是工作。你的人生不应该仅仅存在于工作时间的角落里。生活是每天发生在你身上的事情。它是由美好的快乐、美好的回忆和不可思议的联系所构成的。
That is the most valuable thing to me. And at the end of the day, regardless of the financial risks, regardless of my fears, that was something that I was really looking forward to. and that was something that was really compelling and motivating for me, that I would be able to enjoy my life. So I hope that leaves you with a little bit of wisdom and something to contemplate. I will say it one more time. I think it's worth saying.
这对我来说是最有价值的东西。归根结底，抛开经济风险不谈，抛开我的恐惧不谈，这正是我真正期待的事情，这也是真正吸引我、激励我的事情，那就是我能够享受生活。所以我希望这能给你留下一点智慧和一些值得思考的东西。我要再说一遍。我认为这值得一说。
It's worth acknowledging. I am coming from a place of extreme privilege. And I just want to say I am so grateful. I'm so grateful every day I wake up and I just cannot believe that this is my reality. from a small idea I had back when I was at uni to having so many of you who listen every week. You have really changed my life. You have, like, this would not be possible
这值得认可。我确实处于一种极其优越的地位。我只想说我太感激了。我每天醒来都无比感激，简直不敢相信这就是我的现实。从我上大学时的一个小点子，到拥有每周收听节目的你们这么多人。你们真的改变了我的生活。你们，如果没有
without the people who show their support and who listen to my show and who encourage me. So thank you so much. It means the world. I really don't think I could really ever thank you enough. And I hope that I can continue to just put out even better content, make even more episodes, connect with more of you, and just see what's out there, what science and psychology is doing, how it applies to our 20s and keep building up this guidebook for
那些给予支持、收听我的节目并鼓励我的人，这一切都是不可能实现的。所以非常感谢你们。这对我意义重大。我真的觉得我怎么感谢都不够。我希望我能继续推出更好的内容，制作更多的剧集，与更多的你们建立联系，去看看外面的世界，科学和心理学正在做些什么，它们如何应用于我们的二十几岁，并继续为
people all over the world. So I think that's all we have time for today. Sorry, I went on a bit of an emotional rant, but I think it needed to be said. I am very grateful. If you did enjoy this episode, feel free to share it along to a friend who might need to hear it. And if you do feel cool to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It helps this show to grow. And I really appreciate it. I read all of your reviews, every single one of them. And they are just so personal and beautiful to me.
全世界的人们建立这本指南。我想这就是我们今天的全部时间了。抱歉，我刚才情绪激动地发泄了一通，但我认为这些话非说不可。我非常感激。如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时把它分享给可能需要听到它的朋友。如果你觉得顺理成章，也请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评。这有助于节目的成长。我真的非常感激。我读了你们所有的评论，每一条都是。它们对我来说都非常私密和美好。
So thank you for that support. If you have an episode suggestion, if you have questions, if you just want to give some feedback, please feel free to follow me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. I post a lot of behind-the-scenes content over there, and I'm always looking for new ideas for what you want me to cover. So thank you so much for listening to this episode, and here's your daily reminder to quit your job. And I'll be back next week with another episode.
所以感谢你们的支持。如果你有剧集建议，如果你有疑问，或者只是想提供一些反馈，请随时在Instagram上关注我：That Psychology Podcast。我在那里发布了很多幕后内容，并且一直在寻找关于你想让我涵盖哪些新内容的新想法。非常感谢你收听这一集节目，这是给你的每日提醒：辞职吧。我下周会带着另一集节目回归。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side,
2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你就会从另一端走出来，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》？也就是IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都实在不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次才卖掉，对吧？我篡改测试是一次。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。